From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Bim Adewunmi, in for Ira Glass. My younger cousin, Kamyl, is not really a dog person, but there is one dog she adored. Her name was Foxy, because she looked exactly like a fox, except she was black. She was the neighbor's dog, but she and Kamyl seemed to have a real kinship, maybe because they both weren't very far from the ground.
这里是芝加哥WBEZ电台的《美国生活》。我是Bim Adewunmi，代班Ira Glass。我的小表妹Kamyl并不是特别喜欢狗，但她曾经非常崇拜一只狗。那只狗叫Foxy，因为它长得像狐狸，除了它是黑色的。那是邻居家的狗，但它和Kamyl之间似乎有一种真正的亲缘关系，也许是因为它们俩离地面的距离都不远。
Kamyl was around four or five years old back then, and she had a little lisp, so "Foxy" came out as "Fozhy." I thought it was one of the cutest things I'd ever heard. The way Kamyl remembers Foxy, it's almost like a movie. Her memories feel like endless summer, hazy and perfect, like a scene shot on crackly film.
Kamyl那时大约四五岁，说话还有点口齿不清，所以把“Foxy”说成了“Fozhy”。我觉得那是我听过的最可爱的事情之一。Kamyl记忆中的Foxy，就像一部电影。她的记忆感觉像无尽的夏天，朦胧而完美，就像在带有杂音的胶片上拍摄的一幕。
I just remember the feeling of being excited to go and see Foxy. I have an image in my head of coming to the house, and I could see Foxy was outside. But I can see Foxy through the door that leads to the garden.
我只记得去见Foxy时那种兴奋的感觉。我的脑海里有一个画面：我来到那栋房子，可以看到Foxy在外面。但我可以通过通往花园的那扇门看到它。
There's a story about Kamyl and Foxy that I think about fairly often. I've talked about it with my sister for years, but never with Kamyl. And it's this. Once when they were playing, Foxy nipped at Kamyl, nothing serious, just an excited kid playing with an excited dog. One minute they were playing, half under the coffee table in the middle of the room. And the next, they weren't.
关于Kamyl和Foxy，有一个我经常想起的故事。我和我姐姐谈论过很多年，但从未和Kamyl提起过。事情是这样的：有一次它们在玩耍时，Foxy咬了Kamyl一口，没什么大碍，只是一个兴奋的孩子在和一个兴奋的狗玩。上一刻它们还在房间中间的咖啡桌下玩耍，下一刻它们就不在那里了。
There was no need to go to the hospital or anything, but it was enough to startle Kamyl and to make her cry. But it's what happened after that I think about the most. The day after Foxy nipped her, Kamyl went right back to playing with the dog, but she would not go back to the place where the nip happened.
虽然没必要去医院或做别的什么，但这足以让Kamyl受惊并哭泣。但最让我挂心的是之后发生的事。Foxy咬她后的第二天，Kamyl又回去和那只狗玩了，但她死活不肯回到那个被咬的地方。
If her feet unthinkingly moved her towards the coffee table, she'd redirect. She'd swerve her little body around it. Instead of avoiding the dog, she steered clear of the place. When I brought this up to Kamyl, she had no memory of doing it.
如果她的脚不假思索地朝咖啡桌走去，她就会绕开。她会用她那小小的身体绕过它。她没有避开那只狗，而是避开了那个地方。当我向Kamyl提起这件事时，她根本不记得自己这样做过。
Did anybody try-- did they test me?
有没有人试过——他们测试过我吗？
Yes.
有的。
Did they put a treat in that area and I just would not go there?
他们是不是在那个区域放了零食，然后我就是不肯过去？
I mean, you're talking like you're the dog. [LAUGHS]
我的意思是，你说话就像你自己是那只狗一样。[笑]
Yeah, I guess. Did anyone sit me down to talk about, oh, Kamyl, why don't you go to that corner?
是啊，我想也是。有没有人让我坐下来谈谈，问问“Kamyl，你为什么不去那个角落？”
I don't know. That suggests that we were mature enough to try and help you solve the problem. I think we just found it funny that you avoided the area. I think we were all kind of like, watch this. Watch this. And then we'd try and get you to come around, and then we'd laugh when you wouldn't, which is very cruel, in hindsight. I'm so sorry.
我不知道。那说明我们当时还没成熟到能帮你解决问题。我想我们只是觉得你避开那个区域很有趣。我觉得我们当时都有点像是在看戏，说“看着，看着”，然后我们会试着让你走过来，当你拒绝时我们就笑，事后想来，这真的很残忍。我很抱歉。
And even more curious, Kamyl still seems to have a hard time fathoming this, that Foxy, her beloved friend, could even unwittingly hurt her. 20-ish years later, she still won't let herself go there.
更奇怪的是，Kamyl似乎仍然无法理解这一点：Foxy，她心爱的朋友，竟然会无意中伤害她。大约20年后，她仍然不允许自己去那个地方。
A part of me is like-- you know African parents. They like to overexaggerate. She probably just licked me.
我的一部分心声是——你知道非洲父母。他们喜欢夸大其词。她可能只是舔了我一下。
She didn't lick you. [LAUGHS] She didn't lick you. She definitely nipped you, but I love how-- you're doing it again. You're recasting the past. You're like, no. Did she? She did.
她没舔你。[笑] 她没舔你。她绝对是咬了你，但我喜欢你这样——你又在做了。你正在重塑过去。你在想，不，她是吗？她是这样做的。
Because it's weird. It's weird that I don't remember it. It would be different if I'm like, I don't remember it.
因为这很奇怪。我不记得这件事真的很奇怪。如果我说“我不记得了”，那情况会不一样。
Avoidance is a surprisingly common reaction to information that might knock us off kilter, shying away from the things we cannot wrap our minds around. It's self-preservation. The world is so full of dangerous things, things that might hurt us if we look too closely at them. So we avoid. We circumvent. We choose not to go there.
回避是一种出人意料的常见反应，当我们面对可能让我们不知所措的信息时，我们往往会避开那些无法理解的事情。这是一种自我保护。世界充满了危险的事物，如果看得太仔细，可能会伤害到我们。所以我们回避。我们绕道。我们选择不去那里。
That's our show today in three acts, people finding there's one place in their lives they simply can't access for reasons that, sometimes, even they don't fully understand. There's just a mental "keep out" sign on the door, do not look. Do not pass go. Do not collect $200. Stay with us.
这就是我们今天的节目，分为三幕，讲述人们发现生命中有一个地方他们无法触及，原因有时连他们自己也不完全理解。就像门上挂着一块写着“禁止进入”的心理告示，不要看。不要通过。不要领取200美元。留下来吧。
I Coulda Grown Big in Japan.
我也许能在日本长大。
Atsuko Okatsuka is a comedian, and she's incredibly close with her grandma, Ying-Hsi. They talk several times a day. They're together every weekend. And Atsuko makes these incredible videos of herself dancing, while her grandmother plays incidental hype woman.
Atsuko Okatsuka是一位喜剧演员，她和她的祖母Ying-Hsi关系极其亲密。她们一天要通好几次话。她们每个周末都在一起。Atsuko还会制作那些令人惊叹的自舞视频，而她的祖母则在一旁扮演那种即兴的捧场角色。
Her grandma raised her, but for a while now, Atsuko has joked on stage that her grandmother stole her from her dad when she was little and brought her and her mother from Japan to live in the US.
是祖母把她养大的，但有一段时间，Atsuko在台上开玩笑说，她小时候祖母把她从爸爸身边偷走了，并带她和她母亲从日本搬到美国生活。
From the outside, she looks like this sweet, unassuming old Asian woman, but she's a liar.
从外表看，她看起来像个甜美、谦逊的亚洲老太太，但她是个骗子。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
She a liar. When I was eight, she told me we were coming to the States for a two-month vacation, so I packed lightly. And then we never left. Yeah, true story, yeah, yeah. And till this day, we're still dealing with the kidnapping in our own ways.
她是个骗子。我八岁时，她告诉我我们要来美国度两周假，所以我打包得很轻便。然后我们就再也没离开过。是的，真实的故事。直到今天，我们仍然在以自己的方式处理这场绑架事件。
But the truth is, Atsuko only has the sketchiest idea of what really happened. She doesn't really know how she ended up in America. Her family doesn't discuss it. Talking about it has been a no-go zone for her and her family. But recently, Atsuko decided to find out.
但事实是，Atsuko对到底发生了什么只有极其模糊的概念。她并不真正知道自己是如何来到美国的。她的家人不讨论这件事。谈论这件事一直是她和她家人之间的禁区。但最近，Atsuko决定一探究竟。
Because my family doesn't talk about this, as a kid, all I knew was I was living in Japan, and suddenly I wasn't. I was separated from my dad and my friends. I was forced to go to school in America and learn English and start a new life. I went by "Stacey" for two months. It was jarring and confusing, and I blamed my dad for giving up on us and leaving us in America.
因为我的家人不谈论这件事，小时候我只知道我住在日本，突然间就不是了。我与爸爸和朋友们分开了。我被迫去美国的学校学习英语，开始新的生活。我用了两个月叫“Stacey”的名字。那真是令人震惊和困惑，我责怪爸爸放弃了我们，把我们留在美国。
Then, as an adult, that shifted. I decided my grandma was the bad guy. She stole me away from my dad, and he was the victim. But I never asked anybody the hard questions to find out the actual truth. It was way easier to just talk about it on stage, where nobody could fight you on whether it's real or not. That's why I love standup. Nobody talks back to you. It's good for people who don't want to process feelings.
后来，成年后，这种想法转变了。我认定祖母是坏人。她把我从爸爸身边偷走了，而他是受害者。但我从未问过任何人那些尖锐的问题来弄清真相。在舞台上谈论这件事容易得多，没人能反驳你它是真是假。这就是我喜欢单口喜剧的原因。没人会对你回嘴。这对那些不想处理情绪的人来说很好。
And then my dad had a stroke. He survived it and is recovering, but it was kind of a wake-up call. Am I really going to never ask what happened with my move to the United States? I mean, it was the biggest event in my life. It completely changed everything. Time to get answers. Was I kidnapped? What really happened?
然后我爸爸中风了。他活了下来并正在康复，但这对我来说是一个警钟。难道我真的永远不去问我搬到美国时到底发生了什么吗？我的意思是，那是我生命中最大的事件。它彻底改变了一切。是时候寻找答案了。我被绑架了吗？到底发生了什么？
I'm recording. Test, test. OK. OK. Oh, Grandma--
我在录音。测试，测试。好吧。好吧。噢，祖母——
So I started with my grandma, the perpetrator, and confronted her face to face. She and my mom lived just 20 minutes away.
所以我从我的祖母——那个始作俑者——开始，和她面对面摊牌。她和妈妈就住在20分钟路程外。
Did you kidnap me?
你绑架我了吗？
Oh, no.
噢，没有。
Did you kidnap me?
你绑架我了吗？
No.
没有。
That's what I tell audiences. When I perform I say, yeah, my grandma pretty much kidnapped me.
这就是我告诉观众的。我表演时会说，是的，我祖母基本就是绑架了我。
[SPEAKING MANDARIN]
[说普通话]
[LAUGHS] [SPEAKING MANDARIN]
[笑][说普通话]
She's saying in Mandarin, "There's no such thing. I didn't kidnap you."
她说的是普通话，“没有那种事。我没有绑架你。”
[SPEAKING MANDARIN]
[说普通话]
"When people kidnap a child, they demand money, ransom to return the child. But we didn't ask for that, so it doesn't count as kidnapping."
“当人们绑架孩子时，他们会索要钱财，勒索赎金来换回孩子。但我们没要那个，所以那不算绑架。”
[SPEAKING MANDARIN]
[说普通话]
Oh, OK. She didn't ask for ransom. She's still a kidnapper, she's just bad at it. She took a kid to raise for free. Can you imagine trying to negotiate with a kidnapper, and you're like, please, how much money do you want? I just want my kid back. And they're like, oh, no. It's on me. Free. In fact, I'll take her to LA for you. I think she's going to be a star.
噢，好吧。她没要赎金。她还是个绑架犯，只是手法很烂。她免费带走一个孩子来抚养。你能想象和一个绑架犯谈判吗？你就像说，求你了，你要多少钱？我只想换回我的孩子。然后他们说，噢，不。算我的。免费。实际上，我还帮你把她带到洛杉矶。我觉得她会成为明星的。
I'm glad my grandma and I can joke about these things today. We sat on a couch in her living room. I told her, I think our family has a habit of not speaking about difficult things.
我很高兴我和祖母今天能拿这些事开玩笑。我们坐在她客厅的沙发上。我告诉她，我觉得我们家有一种不谈论困难事情的习惯。
[SPEAKING MANDARIN]
[说普通话]
As we talk, my mom interrupts us from the top of the stairs. My mom lives with her.
我们谈话时，妈妈从楼梯上打断了我们。妈妈和她住在一起。
You guys need to go away.
你们需要离开。
OK, Mom.
好的，妈妈。
[SPEAKING MANDARIN]
[说普通话]
She's asking my grandmother to please not talk about these sad things. It'll affect how I see my life.
她正求祖母不要谈论这些伤心事。这会影响我看待自己生活的方式。
[SPEAKING MANDARIN]
[说普通话]
"It won't. I asked her," I yelled.
“不会的。我问过她了，”我大喊道。
[SPEAKING MANDARIN]
[说普通话]
"Don't say it," she says. "Try not to talk about anything too sad."
“别说了，”她说。“尽量不要谈论太伤心的事情。”
Be happy.
开心点。
It's good to talk about the past.
谈论过去是件好事。
My mom goes back to her room. So a big reason why we don't talk about things is because of my mom. She has paranoid schizophrenia, and talking about sad things can trigger bad memories and the voices in her head.
妈妈回到了她的房间。所以我们不谈论事情的一个很大原因是妈妈。她患有偏执型精神分裂症，谈论伤心事会触发不好的回忆和她脑海中的声音。
So any time we want to talk about the past, we have to tiptoe around her. We whisper or just avoid it completely. And that's how our family has always done things. We didn't even talk about how my mom has schizophrenia. As a kid, my grandma would just say, oh, your mom just has low blood sugar. She's hungry. When she was clearly wilding out, throwing plates at Grandma. It's like, uh, she needs professional help not bread.
所以任何时候如果我们想谈论过去，都必须小心翼翼。我们要么耳语，要么完全避开它。这就是我们家一直以来的做法。我们甚至没有谈论过妈妈患有精神分裂症的事。小时候，祖母只会说，噢，你妈妈只是低血糖。她饿了。明明她当时在疯狂发作，向祖母扔盘子。这就像，呃，她需要专业治疗而不是面包。
I was eager to hear my dad's side of this. For starters, when they divorced, did he have custody of me? Because if he did, this seems way more like a real kidnapping. And did he even know that my grandma was taking me to the US? We talk, like, once a month. We reconnected when I was 15. So I flew to Japan to see him.
我很渴望听到爸爸那一边的说法。首先，他们离婚时，他有我的监护权吗？因为如果有的话，这看起来更像是一场真正的绑架。他甚至知道祖母带我来美国吗？我们大约一个月通一次话。我们在我15岁时重新建立了联系。所以我飞去日本看他。
So we just came from my dad's house. Now we're at my elementary school. This is where I would go to school.
我们刚从爸爸家出来。现在我们在我的小学。这就是我以前上学的地方。
When my dad and I see each other, we try to do as much as we can. He's up for anything, like getting on a big pink dog seesaw with me at the playground to shoot a little video.
当我和爸爸见面时，我们尽量多做些事。他什么都愿意尝试，比如在操场上和我一起坐上那个巨大的粉色狗狗跷跷板拍个小视频。
Reliving childhood, things we never got to do together. Hurry. Have fun. Ahh, ha!
重温童年，那些我们从未一起做过的事。快点。玩得开心。啊，哈哈！
I have all these memories of what it was like to live with my dad. I'd stay up and welcome him home from work. He'd make instant Japanese curry out of a bag for me. Then he would lay on his side on the floor and watch the news before bedtime. I would lay beside him, copying his pose. I wanted to be like him
我有所有关于和爸爸一起生活是什么样的记忆。我会熬夜等他下班回家。他会为我做那种袋装的速食日式咖喱。然后他会侧躺在地板上在睡前看新闻。我会躺在他身边，模仿他的姿势。我想变得像他。
We walk across the street from my old elementary school to an old apartment building. There was a period I lived here, in Japan, with my mom and grandma, separated from my dad.
我们穿过街道，从我以前的小学走到一栋旧公寓楼。有一段时间我住在这里，在日本，和妈妈还有祖母一起，与爸爸分开了。
Me, my mom, and Grandma lived right there. This unit was ours, in fact. It's crazy.
我和妈妈，还有祖母就住在那里。这套房子确实是我们的。太疯狂了。
After I divorced you mother, sometimes I come here, a little drunk, and put in here hundred dollar.
和你妈妈离婚后，有时我会喝点酒，来到这里，放一百美元进去。
Really? Sometimes he would get drunk and just drop off a hundred-dollar bills for us.
真的吗？有时他会喝醉了就给我们留下百元大钞。
[INAUDIBLE]
[听不清]
I didn't know that. Because you missed me?
我不知道。因为你想我了吗？
[INAUDIBLE]
[听不清]
Dad, that's so sad. That's so sad. I miss you all the time. I love you so much. I do.
爸爸，那太令人难过了。那太难过了。我一直都在想你。我非常爱你。我真的爱。
We head across the street.
我们穿过街道。
It's full of sad stories, but I guess I am, too. I feel like a drink already.
到处都是伤心的故事，但我想我也一样。我已经觉得想喝一杯了。
After I came to the US, there were seven years where my dad and I didn't see each other. He wrote me letters, but after a while, I couldn't read them anymore, because my Japanese had gotten so bad. It made me too sad to know we couldn't really communicate anymore, so I stopped writing him back.
我来美国后，有七年时间我和爸爸没见过面。他给我写信，但过了一段时间，我就读不懂了，因为我的日语变差了。无法沟通让我太难过了，所以我停止了回信。
Then, when I was 15, I asked him to come visit, and we've been talking ever since. But it's never been the same as when I used to lay next to him on the floor. Now, I sat him down to do an interview in my hotel room in Tokyo.
然后，我15岁时，我请他来探望，从那以后我们就一直保持联络。但再也不像我过去躺在他身边那样了。现在，我让他坐在东京的酒店房间里接受我的采访。
I had an interpreter help us, so our conversation might sound more formal than usual. We are very Japanese, and a stranger will do that to us. But it also helped us not cry as much, which is really cool and also very Japanese.
我请了一位翻译帮我们，所以我们的谈话可能听起来比平时更正式。我们非常有日本人的风格，外人在场会让我们那样。但也这让我们没那么容易哭出来，这真的很酷，也非常日本。
So when you and Mom separated, what was the arrangement for how much you would see me? What was the custody situation? I'm curious about that.
那么当你和妈妈分开时，对于我会见你多少次有什么安排？监护权的情况是怎样的？我对那个很好奇。
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
[日语]
I have custody. Normally in Japan, when a husband and wife separate, the mother normally gets custody. But when we separated, your mom had a mental illness. So I thought, will your mom be able to take care of you OK?
我有监护权。通常在日本，当丈夫和妻子分开时，母亲通常会获得监护权。但当我们分开时，你妈妈患有精神疾病。所以我想，你妈妈能照顾好你吗？
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
[日语]
So because I was worried about that, I deliberately got custody of you.
所以因为担心那个，我特意争取了你的监护权。
Which means I was kidnapped. It's a kidnapping. I told you it was, but why did my grandma kidnap me? And why didn't he stop it? Before I get to his answer, I should probably explain a little about his relationship with my mom and how unusual it is.
这意味着我被绑架了。这是一场绑架。我告诉过你这是绑架，但为什么祖母要绑架我？他为什么没有阻止？在他回答之前，我应该先解释一下他和妈妈的关系，以及它有多么不同寻常。
This is the part of the story I knew before I flew to Japan. So my mom and dad met through the speed dating event in Japan that my grandma signed my mom up for. She worried my mom was getting older and decided she was going to have to step in if my mom was ever going to find someone.
这是我在飞往日本之前就知道的故事片段。我爸妈是在日本的一个速配活动上认识的，那是祖母给我妈报的名。她担心我妈年纪越来越大，决定如果我妈想找到另一半，她就必须插手。
She and my mom were in Taiwan, so they flew to Tokyo for the event. Yeah, both of them. My grandma has to tag along to everything. That way, she can make sure everything is perfect. That's where my parents met. After just a few dates, they got married, and it was great for a bit, or so my dad has told me.
她和我妈当时都在台湾，所以她们飞到东京参加活动。没错，两人都去了。我祖母什么都要跟着。这样她就能确保一切都完美。我父母就是在那里认识的。几次约会后，他们结婚了，一开始很棒，或者我爸爸是这样告诉我的。
Unfortunately for me, my parents both say their connection had a lot to do with lust, which is cool. I think everyone should experience that in their lives. And honestly, talking about sex is the only time I've ever seen my mom really light up. It's kind of sweet, actually.
不幸的是，我父母都说他们的结合与欲望有很大关系，这很酷。我觉得每个人都应该在生活中体验那种感觉。老实说，谈论性是唯一一次我看到我妈真正神采飞扬。其实那挺甜的。
She told me they'd go to porn theaters together and would make love listening to Elvis. And when they'd get into fights, my mom would accuse my dad of only wanting her for her body. Gross, I know. And then they'd do it even more. Ugh. I'm surprised I don't have siblings. I mean, I do, but they're from my dad's previous marriage.
她告诉我他们会一起去看成人电影，听着猫王的歌做爱。当他们吵架时，我妈会指责爸爸只是因为她的身体才想要她。恶心，我知道。然后他们会做得更频繁。呃。我很惊讶我没有兄弟姐妹。我的意思是，我有，但他们是我爸爸前段婚姻生的。
And that's who my mom moved in with. She became a stepmom to a boy and a girl. And it got pretty bad. I mean, my mom didn't know anybody in Japan. She had no friends. She didn't speak the language. She never even dated anyone before my dad. So then to have to suddenly move in with a family and try to fit in, it was too much.
那就是我妈搬去一起住的对象。她成了一个男孩和一个女孩的继母。情况变得很糟糕。我的意思是，我妈在日本谁也不认识。她没有朋友。她不会说那种语言。她在我爸之前甚至没约会过任何人。所以突然要搬到一个家庭去尝试融入，那压力太大了。
My mom would get jealous whenever my dad paid attention to my half siblings over her. My dad told me she would throw things at them and get wildly abusive. One time, on my sister's birthday, when she had her friends over, my mom came home and lost it at the site of the party. She threw my sister's cake across the room, kicked all her friends out, and then started pulling my sister's hair until my dad stopped her.
只要爸爸关心我的同父异母的兄弟姐妹超过关心她，我妈就会嫉妒。爸爸告诉我，她会向他们扔东西，变得极其辱骂。有一次，在我姐姐生日那天，她有朋友在场，我妈回家后看到聚会场面就崩溃了。她把姐姐的蛋糕扔过房间，把所有朋友踢走，然后开始抓姐姐的头发，直到我爸阻止她。
So they divorced right after they had me. I don't even remember my parents together. After they split up, my mom and grandma went back to Taiwan, and I was living with my dad and his two kids in Chiba, an hour outside of Tokyo. But now my dad tells me things I'd never heard. He says my half siblings didn't really like me because of the way my mom had treated them, and that worried my dad.
所以他们生下我后就离婚了。我甚至不记得我父母在一起的时候。他们分手后，妈妈和祖母回了台湾，而我则和爸爸以及他的两个孩子住在东京外一小时车程的千叶。但现在爸爸告诉我一些我从未听过的事。他说我的同父异母的兄弟姐妹并不真正喜欢我，因为我妈对待他们的方式，那让我爸很担心。
Your relationship with those two children was not very-- I don't really want to say this. But those children were sometimes kind of bullied by your mom. I felt that if everybody lived together that it would not be good. You might be fighting all the time.
你和那两个孩子的关系不是很好——我真的不想说这个。但那些孩子有时被你妈妈欺负。我觉得如果大家都住在一起的话，那不会好。你们可能会一直在吵架。
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
[日语]
Sometimes, he'd dropped me off to live with his parents because of my siblings, and because he was a single dad, already barely holding everything together with a full-time job as an engineer at a big company. And then sometimes, my mom and grandma would take the three-hour flight from Taiwan, and my dad would let them take me back to live with them for short periods.
有时，因为我的兄弟姐妹，也因为他是一个单亲爸爸，还要兼顾大公司工程师的全职工作，他已经很难维持一切了，所以他会把我送到他父母家住。有时，妈妈和祖母会从台湾坐三个小时的飞机过来，爸爸会让她们把我带回去住上一小段时间。
I was like a hot potato, except in this game, everyone wanted me. So I was more like mashed potato? Anyway, I asked my grandma about this, but there's a lot of words I don't know in Mandarin, so I had an interpreter help me. Grandma told me how hard it was for her every time she'd see me, and then had to drop me off again at my dad's.
我就像一个烫手的山芋，只不过在这个游戏中，每个人都想要我。所以我更像是土豆泥？不管怎样，我问了祖母这件事，但有很多普通话词汇我不知道，所以找了翻译帮我。祖母告诉我，每次看到我然后又必须把我送回爸爸那里时，她是多么痛苦。
[SPEAKING MANDARIN]
[说普通话]
I kept crying on my way to the airport. I cried all the way from Japan to Taiwan, because I couldn't bear being away from you.
我在去机场的路上一直在哭。我从日本哭到台湾，因为我无法忍受和你分开。
They heard how mean my half sister was to me, and they saw that my dad had to put me in daycare during the day.
她们听说了同父异母的姐姐对我有多刻薄，也看到爸爸白天必须把我送去托儿所。
[SPEAKING MANDARIN]
[说普通话]
We saw you, how miserable you were. You seemed so lonely. So we decided, without hesitation, that we needed to take you with us.
我们看到你，看到你有多凄惨。你看起来那么孤独。所以我们决定，毫不犹豫地，我们需要带你走。
My dad explained what happened next. So one day, when I was in the first grade and living with him, we went out and ran into my mom and grandma, right in Chiba, where he lives. My dad was really surprised.
爸爸解释了接下来发生的事。有一天，我上小学一年级时住在他那里，我们出门碰到了妈妈和祖母，就在他居住的千叶市。爸爸非常惊讶。
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
[日语]
We ran across each other by chance at the 7-Eleven supermarket. Then they said to me, why don't we talk a little?
我们在7-Eleven超市偶然遇见了。然后她们对我说，我们聊聊好吗？
I like that they just accidentally ran into him, like an ex who's not over the relationship. Like, oh, my god. You shop here, too? What are you doing here? And it's like, yeah. I live here. What are you doing here? You live in Taiwan!
我喜欢她们就像偶遇前任一样碰到了他，就像一个还没放下感情的前任。就像，噢，天哪。你也在这购物？你在这里干什么？而他就像是，是的。我住在这。你在这里干什么？你住在台湾！
Anyway, he agreed to meet with them.
不管怎样，他同意和她们见面。
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
[日语]
So we went to my house in Chiba. It was the four of us, myself, you, your grandma, and your mom. I'm not sure what exactly happened, but you, your mom, and your grandma went outside, and then none of you came back. So it was almost like they ran away or they took you with them.
于是我们去了我在千叶的家。是我们四个人，我，你，你祖母，还有你妈妈。我不确定到底发生了什么，但你、你妈妈和你祖母出去了，然后你们都没回来。所以就像她们逃跑了，或者带走了你。
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
[日语]
It's stories like that that I think back about and worry, like, oh, my gosh. If I were you, I would be so upset. That's like an action movie. That's kidnapping.
像那样的故事我回想起来就很担心，就像，噢，我的天哪。如果我是你，我会非常难过的。那就像一部动作片。那是绑架。
[CHUCKLES]
[轻笑]
That's right. They flew into Chiba from Taiwan, rented an apartment close to him, and took me away after running into my dad at a store. I got to give it to them, that's commitment. I had no idea that's how much they wanted to be with me. Anyway, that was kidnapping number one, almost like a rehearsal for the big heist that would come later.
没错。她们从台湾飞到千叶，在离他很近的地方租了公寓，在店里偶遇我爸爸后把我带走。我得服了她们，那真是执着。我根本不知道她们是那么渴望和我在一起。不管怎样，那是第一场绑架，几乎就像是后来那场大抢劫的彩排。
So I started living with my mom and grandma, just a 15-minute walk away from my dad in that apartment across from my elementary school. I think they stayed in Japan because they didn't want to disrupt my life too much, and they hoped my dad and mom might still get back together.
所以我开始和妈妈及祖母住在一起，离我爸爸住的那间小学对面公寓只有15分钟步行路程。我觉得她们留在日本是因为不想太扰乱我的生活，并且她们希望爸爸妈妈可能会复合。
But during first and second grade, they wouldn't let him see me. I missed him, knowing he was just close by, but I was too scared to ask what was really going on. I didn't want to upset my mom.
但在小学一二年级期间，她们不让他见我。我错过了他，知道他就在附近，但我太害怕而不敢问到底发生了什么。我不想让妈妈难过。
Did you try to see me?
你有试着来看我吗？
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
[日语]
When you are in elementary school for Sports Day, I knew that I could see you. So if I saw you doing well and were healthy, I was just relieved. That's all I felt.
当你在小学参加运动会时，我知道我能见到你。所以如果我看到你表现很好，很健康，我就感到欣慰。那就是我所有的感觉。
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
[日语]
I also felt like I shouldn't directly call out to you or hug you close, so I just watched you from afar.
我也觉得我不应该直接呼唤你或拥抱你，所以我只是远远地看着你。
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
[日语]
He told me he used to watch me through the side gate because he wanted to avoid running into my mom and grandma at the main entrance. I had no idea that went on, that he would watch me alone, afraid to call out to me. I wish he did. I missed him so much.
他告诉我他过去常透过侧门看我，因为他想避免在正门碰到妈妈和祖母。我根本不知道还有那回事，他独自看着我，害怕呼唤我。我真希望他那样做了。我太想念他了。
I told my grandma my dad's version of the story and how sad he was when they took me away from him.
我把爸爸的版本告诉了祖母，还有她们带走我时他有多难过。
[SPEAKING MANDARIN]
[说普通话]
Oh, I understand your dad, because as a parent, it's impossible not to want to see your child. So we empathize with him, but our feelings were complex.
噢，我理解你爸爸，因为作为家长，不可能不想见自己的孩子。所以我们同情他，但我们的感情很复杂。
[SPEAKING MANDARIN]
[说普通话]
I told her, "You know I really like my dad, right?"
我告诉她，“你知道我真的很喜欢我爸爸，对吧？”
[SPEAKING MANDARIN]
[说普通话]
I suppose so, because you were a kind kid, but for us, it was complicated. We were scared that he would take you away.
我想是吧，因为你是个善良的孩子，但对我们来说，情况很复杂。我们害怕他会带走你。
[SPEAKING MANDARIN]
[说普通话]
Also, your mom still resented your dad. That's why she didn't want you to see him, so it became like this.
而且，你妈妈仍然怨恨你爸爸。这就是为什么她不想让你见他，所以就变成了这样。
It went on like this for a year or two, and my grandma was realizing how hard it was to hold everything together. And my mom was getting a lot worse. Grandma says the divorce really changed something in her.
这种情况持续了一两年，祖母意识到要维持一切有多难。妈妈的情况越来越糟。祖母说离婚确实改变了她。
[SPEAKING MANDARIN]
[说普通话]
It really crushed her. There was a period of time when she wanted to hide, and she didn't want to see anyone.
这彻底摧毁了她。有一段时间她想躲起来，不想见任何人。
[SPEAKING MANDARIN]
[说普通话]
What's strange is, I actually don't remember much of my mom from when we were in Japan. I feel like there's memories of me doing things with you, whether we're bicycling outdoors, you taking me to dance classes, me going to the park with you and my friends and then, separately, me doing things with my dad. But I don't remember my mom being in the picture so much. What was she doing? What was her daily schedule like?
奇怪的是，我其实不记得多少在日本时妈妈的事。我觉得我有和你们一起做事的记忆，无论是户外骑行，你带我去上舞蹈课，我和你及朋友去公园，然后，分开地，我做和爸爸在一起的事。但我不太记得妈妈在画面里。她在做什么？她的日常生活是什么样的？
[SPEAKING MANDARIN]
[说普通话]
She was just staying home all day.
她只是整天待在家里。
And just be alone? And she had no friends, right?
然后一个人待着？她没有朋友，对吧？
[SPEAKING MANDARIN]
[说普通话]
Yes.
是的。
But how bad did my mom get? I remember the night where she did take out the kitchen knife and maybe threatened to harm herself or us. But what exactly happened that night, again?
但我妈妈情况变得多糟？我记得那天晚上她确实拿出了菜刀，可能威胁要伤害自己或我们。但那天晚上到底发生了什么？
[SPEAKING MANDARIN]
[说普通话]
There was one time late at night she had a knife in her hand, and it looked like she might want to attack us. I was scared, so I got you out of the house on a bike, and we went around the neighborhood. We biked and biked around the neighborhood till very late, before we went home.
有一次深夜她手里拿着刀，看起来她可能想攻击我们。我很害怕，所以我骑自行车带你离开了家，我们在附近转悠。我们骑啊骑，转了很久，直到很晚才回家。
I mean, my mother would never hurt me. She says that I'm all she has, but that scared my grandma. It put her on high alert. But she couldn't ask my dad for help, because she knew that would upset my mom. So she took charge, like always, and made a big decision.
我的意思是，我母亲永远不会伤害我。她说我是她拥有的一切，但那吓坏了祖母。这让她高度警觉。但她不能向爸爸求助，因为她知道那会让我妈难过。所以她像往常一样负责，并做了一个重大决定。
[SPEAKING MANDARIN]
[说普通话]
I felt like I couldn't protect you and your mom on my own, but if we move to the US, I've got the help of my son and my daughter-in-law. So I decided to move all of us to the US.
我觉得我无法独自保护你和你妈妈，但如果我们搬到美国，我有我儿子和儿媳的帮忙。所以我决定带我们所有人搬到美国。
I feel so much for my grandma in this moment. I didn't know she moved us to America because she was scared for me, that she was feeling so alone and overwhelmed. But I also feel for my dad. Did he know we were moving? And if he did, why didn't he do anything about it? This is one of the things I most wanted to ask my dad about.
这一刻我非常同情我的祖母。我不知道她带我们搬到美国是因为她为我担心，她感到如此孤独和不知所措。但我同样同情我的父亲。他知道我们要搬走吗？如果他知道，他为什么没做点什么？这是我最想问爸爸的事情之一。
I did not know we were moving to America. Did you know?
我不知道我们要搬到美国。你知道吗？
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
[日语]
Did I know from the very beginning? No, I didn't know.
我从一开始就知道吗？不，我不知道。
Grandma confirmed this. She didn't tell him, not before we left. He realized it later.
祖母证实了这一点。她没告诉他，在我们离开之前。他后来才意识到。
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
[日语]
Right now, I'm almost about to cry a little. So basically, your grandma told me in a letter that you are really missing me, and that's when I think I knew you were in America. I really wanted to see you, too.
现在，我几乎要哭出来了。所以基本上，你祖母在信里告诉我你真的很想我，那时我想我就知道你在美国了。我也真的很想见你。
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
[日语]
I have some feelings of guilt that, as a child, because I love both Mom and Dad and Grandma, I love everyone so much. So sometimes I fear that in the past, maybe I hurt your feelings if I said I wanted to go with Mom and Grandma. But I want you to know that I was just a confused kid who wanted to see everyone equally, so I want you to know that I always, always wanted to be with you, too.
我有种负罪感，作为孩子，因为我爱妈妈、爸爸和祖母，我爱每个人。所以有时我担心过去，如果我说我想和妈妈及祖母在一起，可能会伤害你的感情。但我希望你知道我只是一个困惑的孩子，想平等地看到每个人，所以我想让你知道我一直、一直也想和你在一起。
Then my dad told me something that completely shattered everything I thought I knew going into this. He said that back then, he thought maybe it was better for me to be with my mom and grandma. He was working all the time, and my siblings were mean to me.
然后爸爸告诉我的一件事彻底粉碎了我所知道的一切。他说，那时他认为也许让我和妈妈及祖母在一起对我更好。他一直在工作，而我的兄弟姐妹对我不好。
He felt he couldn't provide the best environment for me. And here were my mom and grandma, so excited to have me. Maybe I should be with them, he thought. That's why he didn't fight to keep me. This was all news to me.
他觉得他不能给我最好的环境。而妈妈和祖母，她们如此兴奋地拥有我。也许我应该和她们在一起，他想。这就是他没为留住我而战的原因。这些对我来说都是新消息。
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
[日语]
So I've never gotten angry about it but, I felt disappointed, naturally.
所以我从没对此感到生气，但，自然地，我感到失望。
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
[日语]
I kind of felt it can't be helped. Your mom and grandma felt that even though I had custody, when they saw you, they just loved you so much that they wanted to be with you. And so they took you with them. I think those feelings are natural, so I didn't get angry.
我有点觉得那无法避免。你妈妈和你祖母觉得，尽管我有监护权，但当她们看到你，她们真的很爱你，她们想和你在一起。所以她们带走了你。我觉得这些感受很自然，所以我没生气。
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
[日语]
I admire how much you have empathy for other people.
我很钦佩你有多少对他人的同理心。
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
[日语]
Thank you. Thank you, Atsuko. So right now, you are praising me. But if I really understood people's feelings, I wouldn't have made so many mistakes in my life.
谢谢。谢谢你，Atsuko。所以现在，你在称赞我。但如果我真的理解人们的感受，我就不会在生活中犯这么多错误了。
[SPEAKING JAPANESE]
[日语]
It's interesting that my dad thought he was looking out for my best interests by letting me go. It broke his heart and mine, too. But he did it for me. He could have confronted my grandma, just like my grandma could have told him the truth about taking me to America.
有趣的是，爸爸以为放我走是为我好。这让他心碎，也让我心碎。但他确实是为了我。他本可以面对我的祖母，就像我祖母本可以告诉他关于带我来美国的真相一样。
But this is one way they're similar. They avoid these conversations, because when you converse, there's conflict. And my family, we don't like that. They could have done it, though, and they could have talked to me. I would have asked to go back to Japan. I would have asked to see both my parents equally. They could figure out the details from there, summers in America, school year in Japan, maybe. Who knows? They're the adults. I was eight years old.
但这是他们相似的一点。他们回避这些谈话，因为当谈话时，会有冲突。而我们家，不喜欢那样。不过他们本可以那样做，本可以和我谈谈。我会要求回日本。我会要求平等地见我的父母。他们可以从那里解决细节，暑假在美国，学期在日本，也许吧。谁知道呢？他们是成年人。我当时八岁。
Before we left for America, my friends from second grade in Japan threw a farewell party for me. But I thought it was just them being dramatic, because I was coming back. I liked the attention, though. We were at a McDonald's, and everyone brought me gifts. They also wrote me tons of letters, too, that I discovered years later in a box. They all said they were going to miss me. So pretty much all of Chiba knew I was leaving for good, except for me and my dad. It's like The Truman Show directed by my grandma.
在我们去美国之前，我在日本二年级的朋友为我举办了告别派对。但我以为只是她们在装模作样，因为我会回来的。但我喜欢那种关注。我们在麦当劳，每个人都给我送礼物。她们还写了大量的信给我，我多年后在箱子里发现了。她们都说会想我。所以基本上整个千叶都知道我永远离开了，除了我和我爸爸。就像我祖母导演的《楚门的世界》。
[SPEAKING MANDARIN]
[说普通话]
I told her, "When you brought me here without telling me or my dad, you knew we'd find out one day, right? Did you think about that?"
我告诉她，“当你带我来这里却没告诉我或爸爸时，你知道我们终有一天会发现的，对吧？你想过那个吗？”
[SPEAKING MANDARIN]
[说普通话]
I guess I thought, whatever happens, happens. I just let everything unfold.
我想我当时想的是，无论发生什么，就发生吧。我只是让一切顺其自然。
I love that when it comes to intense things, my grandma's got a surfer attitude about it. She's all, ride the wave, bruh. It's just America. But this is how she generally deals with stuff in life. She raised three kids on her own after her husband died, and she just pushes ahead and figures something will work out. It has to.
我喜欢我祖母在面对强烈的事情时有一种冲浪者的态度。她就是，去顺应潮流吧，哥们。只是美国而已。但这就是她处理生活事务的方式。她在丈夫去世后独自抚养了三个孩子，她只是勇往直前，觉得总会有办法的。必须如此。
For years, she supported her kids by teaching English in Taiwan, without really speaking English. It was just another one of the scams she pulled. With a smile on her face and a few lies, she always figured it out. That's what she did with me.
多年来，她通过在台湾教英语来供养她的孩子，而她并不真正会说英语。这只是她耍的另一个把戏。带着脸上的微笑和一点谎言，她总是能搞定。这就是她对我做的事。
[SPEAKING MANDARIN]
[说普通话]
I was worried that you would feel upset, so I had to trick you. Sorry. I'm sorry.
我担心你会难过，所以我不得不骗你。抱歉。我很抱歉。
So you lied, and [SPEAKING MANDARIN]
所以你撒谎了，而且 [说普通话]
When summer ended and she enrolled me in school in Los Angeles, that's when I realized we weren't going home. I started dreaming of being back in Japan, being with my friends, being with my dad. I had that dream every night.
当夏天结束，她给我报名洛杉矶的学校时，我才意识到我们不会回家了。我开始梦见回到日本，和朋友在一起，和爸爸在一起。我每晚都做那个梦。
[SPEAKING MANDARIN]
[说普通话]
I didn't know about this. I'm sorry. I didn't know.
我不知道这件事。我很抱歉。我不知道。
[SPEAKING MANDARIN]
[说普通话]
I asked, "Did I cry or ask why we're still here? Did I tell you I wanted to see my dad?
我问，“我有没有哭或问为什么我们还在这里？我有没有告诉你我想见爸爸？”
[SPEAKING MANDARIN]
[说普通话]
As far as I recall, you did not. I don't know how you felt deep down, but on the surface, you seemed OK.
据我回忆，你没有。我不知道你内心深处是什么感受，但在表面上，你看上去还好。
[SPEAKING MANDARIN]
[说普通话]
You were a very considerate and thoughtful child, and you probably didn't want to worry us. Maybe you were upset, but you didn't want to show us.
你是个非常体贴和懂事的孩子，你可能不想让我们担心。也许你很伤心，但你不想向我们表现出来。
The one thing that I didn't tell you, that I wasn't honest with you, was that we were moving to the US, and we would never come back to Japan.
我没有告诉你的一件事，我没对你诚实的一件事，就是我们要搬到美国，而且我们永远不会回到日本了。
[SPEAKING MANDARIN]
[说普通话]
This is my biggest regret.
这是我最大的遗憾。
[SPEAKING MANDARIN]
[说普通话]
It feels like I deceived you. I know you were upset at that time. I feel really bad about it. I'm sorry.
感觉就像我欺骗了你。我知道你当时很难过。我对此感觉真的很糟。我很抱歉。
[SPEAKING MANDARIN]
[说普通话]
I told her, "No need to keep apologizing. No need to be sad." Before I started these interviews, I thought either my grandma was the villain for stealing me from my dad or that my dad was for deserting me once we got to the States. And it turns out, the truth is, my grandma did take me away. And my dad could have done something to stop it, but he decided I'd be better off without him, which is so much sadder and somehow feels worse. I just feel so bad for all of them.
我告诉她，“没必要一直道歉。没必要伤心。”在开始这些访谈之前，我以为要么是祖母为了从爸爸身边偷走我是个反派，要么是爸爸因为到美国后抛弃我是个反派。事实证明，真相是，祖母确实带走了我。而爸爸本可以做点什么阻止，但他决定没有他我会更好，这更令人难过，不知怎的感觉更糟。我真为他们所有人感到难过。
Thank you for answering that. And thank you for being with me today, and I love you so much. And thank you for everything you have ever done for me, Grandma. I mean that from the bottom of my heart.
谢谢你回答那个。也谢谢你今天陪我，我非常爱你。谢谢你为我做的一切，祖母。我从心底里那样说。
[SPEAKING MANDARIN]
[说普通话]
Grandma tells the translator, "Oh, thank her, too. I am also very grateful for her."
祖母告诉翻译，“噢，也谢谢她。我也非常感激她。”
It's the least I can do. Maybe I have Stockholm syndrome. I'm just kidding. [LAUGHS]
这是我能做的最少的了。也许我有斯德哥尔摩综合征。开玩笑的。[笑]
Well, I confronted her about it recently. I was like, Grandma, did you kidnap me? Because that's what I tell people on stage.
好吧，我最近和她谈过这件事。我说，祖母，你绑架我了吗？因为那就是我在舞台上告诉人们的。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
She was like, hey, at least because I brought you to the states, you became a comedian, a successful one. And I was like, keep going. And then she backtracked. She was like, wait. But what if you didn't find comedy? What would you have done? And I was like, well, then I guess I'd have to press charges. [LAUGHTER]
她说，嘿，至少因为我带你来美国，你成为了喜剧演员，一个成功的喜剧演员。然后我说，继续。然后她退缩了。她说，等等。但如果你没发现喜剧呢？你会做什么？我说，好吧，那我想我得起诉你了。[笑声]
Atsuko Okatsuka is a comedian. You can watch her HBO special. It's called The Intruder. She's also currently on tour with her new show. Tickets at AtsukoComedy.com. This story was produced by Ira Glass, with Miki Meek and Diane Wu.
Atsuko Okatsuka是一位喜剧演员。你可以看她的HBO特别节目。名字叫《入侵者》。她目前也在巡演她的新秀。门票在AtsukoComedy.com。这个故事由Ira Glass制作，Miki Meek和Diane Wu共同制作。
Coming up, a faraway planet and the alien whose spaceship just can't land there. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
即将到来，一颗遥远的星球，以及那艘无法降落在那里的外星飞船。从芝加哥公共广播电台，我们的节目继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Bim Adewunmi, sitting in for Ira Glass. Today's program, The One Place I Can't Go, all about the mental roadblocks that people set up to keep them from engaging with thorny issues. We've arrived at Act 2 of our show.
这里是《美国生活》。我是Bim Adewunmi，代班Ira Glass。今天的节目，“我无法去的地方”，全部关于人们为了避免接触棘手问题而设置的心理路障。我们到了节目的第二幕。
Act Two, Killing Me Softly.
第二幕，温柔地杀了我。
My colleague, Emmanuel Dzotsi, he has a tale about something he avoids at all costs. Even though it seems to follow him everywhere he goes. It's been like this for years. Here's Emmanuel.
我的同事Emmanuel Dzotsi有一个关于他竭尽全力回避的事物的故事。尽管它似乎随处可见。这种状况已经持续多年了。有请Emmanuel。
What I'm about to tell you is not some funny story I tell at parties. In fact, I don't really talk about it at all. The thing I don't talk about is a song.
我接下来要告诉你的不是我在聚会上讲的什么有趣的故事。事实上，我基本不谈论它。我不谈论的那个东西是一首歌。
I don't talk about it because for over 10 years, anytime I listen to, sing, hum, or even think about it, it gets stuck in my head. And when that happens, bad things happen to me, often immediately. I've lost keys, wallets, my Social Security card after listening to this song. I lost a relationship once, got dumped after it played in a coffee shop I was in.
我不谈论它是因为十多年来，任何时候我听、唱、哼，甚至想到它，它就会在我脑海中挥之不去。当这种情况发生时，坏事就会发生在我身上，通常是立刻。听过这首歌后，我丢过钥匙、钱包、社保卡。我丢过一段感情，在一家我呆的咖啡店播放这首歌后被甩了。
I'm not a superstitious person, but I truly believe it is the ultimate bad luck for me. Right before I sat down to write this, no joke, I made sure to renew my renter's insurance, just in case. That's how seriously I take this song.
我不是个迷信的人，但我真的相信这是我终极的坏运气。就在我坐下来写这个之前，不骗你，我确保更新了我的租房保险，以防万一。我就是这么认真地对待这首歌。
The first time I heard it, I was a freshman in college. YouTube suggested it to me during a morning study session for a midterm I had later that day. I remember listening to it and feeling so happy. I was having a great day, and the song was my soundtrack. I remember that feeling staying with me for hours, hearing the song in my head as I took the midterm. It was still playing in my head a few days later, when I got the results back and saw that I'd failed.
第一次听到它时，我是大学新生。YouTube在当天晚些时候的一次期中考试早晨学习中向我推荐了它。我记得听着它感到非常开心。那天过得很棒，这首歌是我的配乐。我记得那种感觉伴随了我好几个小时，我在参加期中考试时，脑海里一直响着这首歌。几天后，当我收到成绩看到挂科时，它还在我脑子里响着。
At the time, I didn't blame the song. I was just like, well, that's what I get for taking a class about black holes. I moved on. In fact, I added the song to a long playlist I had.
当时，我没责怪那首歌。我只是想，好吧，这就是选修黑洞课的代价。我继续前行。事实上，我把这首歌加进了我的长播放列表里。
A few weeks later, when I was listening to music in the middle of the day after some classes, the song played, and I fell asleep while listening, slept through a work shift I had, and got fired for the first and only time in my life. I just need more sleep, I told myself. It's a coincidence.
几周后，我在课后中午听音乐时，这首歌响了，我在听的时候睡着了，错过了工作班次，这辈子第一次也是唯一一次被开除。我告诉自己，我只是需要更多睡眠。这只是巧合。
But then, months later, the next time this song came on, I found myself feeling weirdly on edge. I thought about skipping it. But just as quickly, I also thought, that's ridiculous. So I kept the song playing. Later that day, after a concert band rehearsal, I put my backpack down to help a friend move some chairs, and somebody stole it, presumably for the laptop inside. I went in the rest of the semester without a personal computer. I was freaked out.
但后来，几个月后，这首歌再次响起时，我发现自己感到莫名其妙地焦躁。我想跳过它。但转念一想，这太荒谬了。所以我让歌继续播放。那天晚些时候，音乐队排练后，我放下背包去帮朋友搬椅子，有人把它偷走了，大概是为了里面的笔记本电脑。那学期剩余时间我都没有个人电脑。我吓坏了。
You know how in horror movies, there's always that moment where the happy couple finally realize they might not have booked a great weekend getaway at a cabin after all and that the vibes are most definitely off? That's what it felt like.
你知道恐怖电影里总是有那种情侣终于意识到他们可能根本没有订到度假小屋，而且气氛绝对不对劲的时刻吗？就是那种感觉。
After that, even though I knew it wasn't rational, I tried to avoid the song. But it didn't work. The only bike accident I've ever been in happened after I heard it being played by a passing car. One time, it came on during a long road trip. And the next time I stopped, I noticed a nail in one of my tires.
在那之后，虽然我知道这不理智，但我试图回避那首歌。但没用。我有史以来唯一一次自行车事故是在一辆经过的汽车播放这首歌后发生的。有一次，在一场长途驾驶中它响了。下一次停车时，我注意到轮胎上钉了一颗钉子。
When I was preparing to run my first marathon, I was putting together a playlist, and my phone played a bit of a song before I could turn it off. A few hours later, my sister called me and told me, Emmanuel, our parents are getting divorced.
准备参加我的第一次马拉松时，我正在整理播放列表，我还没来得及关掉，手机就播放了一小段音乐。几个小时后，姐姐给我打电话说，Emmanuel，我们的父母要离婚了。
The next morning, I forgot to bring my headphones to the race, and, for the nearly five hours it took me to run the marathon, all I could think about were my parents, their marriage, and that song, which happens to be a sappy love song, endlessly looping in my head.
第二天早上，我忘了带耳机去比赛，在跑马拉松所需的近五个小时里，我脑海里只能想到我的父母、他们的婚姻，以及那首歌——它恰好是一首多愁善感的爱情歌曲，无休止地在我脑海里循环。
I know all of this sounds delusional. A couple of years ago, I tried to convince myself, once and for all, that the song was just a song, but it backfired spectacularly. I decided to play it every day for a month. I'd wake up, play the song, and then walk around the rest of the day telling myself not to worry.
我知道这一切听起来像妄想。几年前，我试着彻底说服自己，这首歌只是一首歌，但它适得其反。我决定连续一个月每天播放它。我会醒来，播放这首歌，然后在那天余下的时间里走来走去告诉自己不要担心。
When nothing bad happened for three days, I felt relieved. And then, on the fourth day, I suffered a freak wrist injury, which plagued me for nine months. To make matters worse, because I'd played it so much, Spotify kept pushing me the song for months after the accident, because it thought I wanted to hear it.
当三天里什么坏事都没发生时，我感到如释重负。然后，在第四天，我遭遇了一次离奇的手腕受伤，折磨了我九个月。更糟糕的是，因为我播放得太多，事故发生后的好几个月，Spotify一直在向我推送这首歌，因为它以为我想听它。
That year was, by far, the worst year of my 20s. My hair, which, until that point, was decently robust, started falling out aggressively. My long-time family cat died. I went through a massive breakup. My professional life was a mess. And I got COVID right before Christmas, so I spent my first-ever Christmas completely alone.
那一年是我二十多岁里最糟糕的一年。我的头发，在那之前还是相当浓密的，开始疯狂掉落。陪伴我多年的家庭猫死了。我经历了一次巨大的分手。我的职业生涯一团糟。圣诞节前夕我感染了新冠，所以我独自一人度过了有史以来第一个圣诞节。
And it pushed me to do something I should have done years earlier. I added the group that sings the song to my do-not-play list on Spotify, which is a shame, because I really like the song. It is good with a capital G.
这促使我做了一件我应该早几年做的事。我把这首歌的演唱组合加入了我的Spotify禁止播放列表，这很遗憾，因为我真的很喜欢这首歌。它是那种“大G”意义上的好歌。
It is one of those R&B disco ballads from the '70s that is so ridiculously happy, so positive, it makes you wonder if the '70s were the most optimistic Americans have ever been or if things were actually so bleak artists had to make songs like this one. But yeah, no, I will not be playing this song or naming it. It's poison to me.
它是那种70年代的R&B迪斯科情歌之一，如此滑稽地快乐，如此积极，让你怀疑70年代是否是美国人有史以来最乐观的时期，还是当时的情况真的很惨淡，以至于艺术家们不得不创作这样的歌曲。但是的，不，我不会播放这首歌或说出它的名字。它是我的毒药。
A skeptical friend of mine pointed out that yes, bad things happen when I hear this song, but don't bad things happen to all of us all the time? Maybe I just noticed them when the song plays. He suggested I try to keep track of every unfortunate event I encounter without the song so I could see, once and for all, there was nothing to this.
我的一位怀疑论者朋友指出，是的，当我听到这首歌时坏事发生了，但坏事不是一直发生在所有人身上吗？也许我只是在歌响的时候注意到了它们。他建议我尝试记录下我遇到的每一件不幸事件，不听这首歌，这样我就能一劳永逸地看出这根本没什么。
And so I did it. I listed every tiny thing over the course of a couple of weeks, and I was surprised by how many there were, even if they were small. I cut myself on a metal can, accidentally got bleach on one of my favorite T-shirts, got into a never-ending back and forth with my health insurance over almost 20 claims they didn't want to pay. I spent half of a family wedding in the ER because a guest passed out at the reception.
于是我做了。我在几周内列出了每一件微小的事情，我很惊讶竟然有这么多，即使它们都很小。我不小心被金属罐割伤，不小心把漂白剂弄到我最喜欢的一件T恤上，和我的健康保险公司在近20个他们不想支付的理赔单上进行无休止的往来。我在参加一场家庭婚礼时，有一半时间都在急诊室，因为有个客人在招待会上晕倒了。
I know I'm supposed to look at that list and feel freed, feel finally able to listen to that song whenever I want, but-- don't judge me-- all it did was convince me that lousy stuff happens to me a lot. So why would I risk playing this song and making it worse?
我知道我本该看着那份清单感到解脱，感到终于能随时随地听那首歌了，但是——别评判我——它所做的只是让我确信糟糕的事情经常发生在我身上。所以我为什么要冒着播放这首歌让事情变得更糟的风险呢？
I have nothing else like this in my life. I don't believe in astrology. I don't believe in luck. I don't believe that misfortune is God punishing you for your bad deeds. I know it's entirely possible that when I hear that tune I freak out in a way that causes unpleasant things to happen to me. But this I believe. I have to stay away from this song.
我的生活中没有其他这样的东西了。我不相信占星术。我不相信运气。我不相信不幸是上帝对你恶行的惩罚。我知道完全有可能当我听到那段旋律时，我以一种导致不愉快事情发生的方式吓坏了自己。但我相信这一点。我必须远离这首歌。
Emmanuel Dzotsi is a producer on our show. Right after working on the final draft of this piece, he went for a run in the woods, got chased by a loose dog, and fell, bruising his ribs and busting his ankle. As of this taping, he's also home sick with strep throat.
Emmanuel Dzotsi是我们节目的制作人。在完成这篇稿件的最终定稿后，他去树林里跑步，被一只没拴绳的狗追赶，摔倒了，擦伤了肋骨并挫伤了脚踝。在这次录音时，他还因为链球菌性咽喉炎在家病休。
Act Three, Lost in Space.
第三幕，迷失在太空中。
This last story is about someone who spent her childhood craving a world that she could not find on Earth, so, as an adult, she just created one. And it was perfect until she became the one person who couldn't go there. Lilly Sullivan has the story.
这最后一个故事关于一个童年渴望在地球上找不到的世界的人，所以，成年后，她创造了一个。那曾经是完美的，直到她成了唯一一个无法进入那里的人。Lilly Sullivan有这个故事。
First let me tell you about the world she created. It's called The Locked Tomb. It starts on an isolated planet.
首先让我告诉你她创造的世界。它被称为《锁墓》。它始于一个孤立的星球。
And it is a fundamentally dying monastery of a planet, where there are pretty much only three people under 30.
那是一个从根本上垂死的修道院星球，基本上只有三个30岁以下的人。
This is Tamsyn Muir. She's the author of this series of science fantasy books, which begin on that sad planet. But they are also some of the most breezily gay books I've ever read. The blurb on the cover of the first book basically just says, "Lesbian necromancers in space." So I was in.
这是Tamsyn Muir。她是这个科学奇幻系列书籍的作者，这些书始于那个悲伤的星球。但它们也是我读过的最随性、最酷儿的书籍之一。第一本书封底的简介基本上只是说，“太空中的女同性恋通灵师”。所以我进去了。
Reading the first one was unlike anything I've ever read. Here's first line. "In the myriadic year of our Lord, the 10,000th year of the king undying, the kindly prince of death, Gideon Nav packed her sword, her shoes, and her dirty magazines. And she escaped from the house of the night." Gideon is a Cavalier, which is kind of like a knight, but she's not like a classic knight. She refers to people as douchebags, and she's constantly saying things like, "That's what she said."
读第一本时的体验不同于我读过的任何东西。这是第一行。“在主宰的万世之年，不朽之王、仁慈的死亡之君执政的第一万年，Gideon Nav带上了她的剑、鞋子和她的色情杂志。她逃离了夜晚之屋。” Gideon是一名骑士（Cavalier），有点像骑士，但她不像那种经典骑士。她称呼别人为混蛋，而且经常说像“她就是这么说的”之类的话。
Unlike most queer books, there's barely any sex or romance or making out. The words "gay," "lesbian," "queer" never even show up. People are queer, but it's more like their personalities, their humor. It's just understood. And I'll just say, I'm sure these books aren't for everyone, but I love them.
与大多数酷儿书籍不同，这里几乎没有性、浪漫或接吻。词汇“同性恋”、“女同性恋”、“酷儿”甚至从未出现过。人们是酷儿，但这更多是关于他们的个性、幽默。这只是心领神会。我只想说，我相信这些书并不适合每个人，但我爱它们。
I read the first book one summer a few years ago. I was on vacation with a few friends, and we all got pulled into it at the same time. And it was like we all just fell into this kind of imaginary space that Tamsyn had created, kind of youthful and very gay, in a fun rather than oppressive way, which, Tamsyn says, is exactly what she'd hoped for. Tamsyn says she wrote this book for her 17-year-old self, who really could have used books and worlds like this back then.
几年前的一个夏天我读了第一本。我和几个朋友度假，我们同时被吸引进去了。就像我们都掉进了Tamsyn创造的那种虚构空间，青春且非常酷儿，是以一种有趣而非压抑的方式，Tamsyn说，这正是她所希望的。Tamsyn说她为17岁的自己写了这本书，当年的她真的很需要这样的书和世界。
Just ways to be queer that weren't inherently sad. The very mainstream LGBQT stuff, it was miserable. And I was already miserable, because if I wanted to read gay literature at the time, it was always like, my sad, coming-out summer. And yeah, I didn't want to read my sad coming-out summer for the umpty-umpth time. I'd read it. It was good the first 50 times.
就是那些非本质上悲伤的酷儿方式。非常主流的LGBT内容，都很悲惨。我已经很悲惨了，因为如果当时我想读酷儿文学，总是像：我悲伤的出柜之夏。是的，我不想第N次读我的悲伤出柜之夏。我读过了。前50次读起来还不错。
What I really wanted was a big set piece fight. I wanted to read about girls doing big set piece fights. I mean, that was the era of The Matrix, and I'd also just gotten super into Hong Kong kung fu cinema. And all I did was imagine big kung fu fights.
我真正想要的是一场大型场景战斗。我想读关于女孩们进行大型场景战斗的故事。我的意思是，那是《黑客帝国》的时代，我也刚对香港功夫电影着迷。我做的全部事就是想象大型功夫战斗。
Tamsyn ended up dropping out of high school. She says she wasn't a good student. She'd been put in the class for the, quote, "stupid kids." She said she spent most of high school dyeing her hair, shaving it ways nobody liked, sitting in the back of the class, her eyes glazed over, daydreaming about big martial arts fights. She came out in high school, in a small conservative New Zealand suburb, a different era.
Tamsyn最终从高中辍学。她说她不是个好学生。她被分进了所谓的“傻瓜班”。她说她大部分高中时光都在染发，剪成没人喜欢的样子，坐在教室后面，目光呆滞，做着大型武术打斗的白日梦。她在高中出柜，在一个保守的小型新西兰郊区，一个不同的时代。
And one of my best friends stopped talking to me immediately. And I don't even blame her. I think a lot of people forget how dangerous and grotesque being gay was presented back at the time.
我最好的朋友之一立刻停止和我说话。我甚至不怪她。我觉得很多人都忘了那个时代对同性恋的呈现有多危险和荒诞。
She was bullied, beaten up. And to escape, she wrote stories, which is not such a surprise given where she was hanging out online. It's a place she stumbled on when she was about 11.
她被欺负、殴打。为了逃避，她写故事，考虑到她在网上混迹的地方，这并不奇怪。那是她11岁左右偶然发现的地方。
My dad had been on ARPANET, so was that connected with old-school internet. And the internet of 1996 was just a wild frontier. That was cowboy territory. Anything was happening. And I just wanted to look up cool pictures of Sailor Moon or go on ICQ and talk about animals and gargoyles, and I found fanfiction, and I didn't look back.
我爸爸曾参与过ARPANET，所以那是与老派互联网连接的。1996年的互联网只是一个狂野的边疆。那是牛仔领地。任何事情都在发生。我只是想查找《美少女战士》的酷图，或者在ICQ上谈论动物和石像鬼，我发现了同人小说，从此一去不回。
Fanfiction, a whole world of people equally obsessed with stories and sci-fi, to the point they were going online to write their own versions of the stories they loved, X-Files, Lord of the Rings. They fix the things they feel the author got wrong. There's tons of shipping, that is, people deciding which characters should have ended up together and rewriting it so that they do.
同人小说，一个沉迷于故事和科幻的群体，以至于他们上网编写自己所爱故事的版本，比如《X档案》、《指环王》。他们修复他们觉得作者写错的地方。这里有大量的配对（shipping），也就是说，人们决定哪些角色应该在一起，并改写它使之成真。
None of this is for money, for the most part. It's just for fun. Tamsyn was just a kid, but she starts publishing stories there, stuff she never would have taken to school. It's the first place she ever published anything, the first place she ever really showed anyone her work.
大部分情况下，这些都不是为了钱。只是为了好玩。Tamsyn当时还是个孩子，但她开始在那里发表故事，那些她绝不会带去学校的东西。这是她发表任何作品的第一个地方，她真正向任何人展示作品的第一个地方。
And I think one of the reasons I got into it initially was because it felt so illegal and faintly naughty. Fanfiction, especially back then, was like the dark web for nerds. You read a story, and the author's note immediately says, please don't sue me. It's like punk for dorks.
我认为我最初参与其中的原因之一是因为它感觉如此非法且隐约有些调皮。同人小说，尤其是在当时，就像是书呆子的暗网。你读一个故事，作者说明里立刻写着，请不要起诉我。这就像书呆子的朋克。
Punk for dorks, in other words, her people. A lot of people think of fanfic as lowbrow, embarrassing. A lot of big sci-fi fantasy writers slam it. George R. R. Martin, who wrote Game of Thrones, has said it's copyright infringement, a violation of intellectual property. Anne Rice, who wrote Interview With the Vampire, has famously objected to people writing fic about her stories, because who wouldn't want to ship Brad Pitt and Tom Cruise?
书呆子的朋克，换句话说，她的人。很多人认为同人小说是低俗、尴尬的。许多大牌科幻奇幻作家抨击它。《权力的游戏》作者George R. R. Martin曾说这是侵犯版权，侵犯知识产权。《夜访吸血鬼》作者Anne Rice曾名声在外地反对人们写关于她故事的同人，因为谁不想把Brad Pitt和Tom Cruise配对呢？
There are some writers who, like Tamsyn, write fic before going mainstream. But once they make it mainstream, they might delete their accounts, delete all the things they wrote pre-mainstream days. Not Tamsyn. Tamsyn still loves these worlds. When the first book in the series came out, Gideon the Ninth, it was a big deal, nominated for the biggest sci-fi awards.
有一些作家像Tamsyn一样在进入主流之前写同人。但一旦他们进入主流，他们可能会删除账号，删除在主流之前写的那些东西。不是Tamsyn。Tamsyn仍然热爱这些世界。该系列的第一本书《九号基甸》（Gideon the Ninth）问世时，引起了轰动，获得了科幻最高奖项提名。
A review in The New York Times called it "meticulous and moody, haunted by difficult and complex feelings in a wasted universe." And in all this excitement about the book, Tamsyn heard about some buzz from the place where she'd always felt so comfortable, one of the main fanfiction sites, AO3, or Archive of Our Own. One day, she saw something she'd never seen before. People had started writing fanfic about her work.
《纽约时报》的一篇评论称其为“严谨而忧郁，被荒凉宇宙中复杂而困难的情感所困扰”。在所有关于这本书的兴奋中，Tamsyn听到了一些来自她一直感到舒适的地方的嗡嗡声，主要的同人小说网站之一，AO3或“我们的档案”（Archive of Our Own）。一天，她看到了她从未见过的事物。人们开始写关于她作品的同人小说。
And I think I saw there were eight fanfics. And I was like, oh, oh, oh. I'm feeling a lot of different emotions, and I have to run away right now. I cannot look at even what these titles are.
我想我看到有八篇同人小说。我就想，噢，噢，噢。我感觉到了许多不同的情绪，我必须立刻跑开。我连这些标题是什么都不能看。
Why?
为什么？
You know inherently starting out in fan fiction that you are not allowed to read it if it's for your own creation.
你本质上知道，一旦开始写同人小说，如果是为了你自己的创作，你是不允许阅读它的。
What are the reasons?
原因是什么？
So I think one of the main things is that you worry that if you read fan fiction and then you write anything that mimics anything that somebody has written about your property, you just committed a huge cardinal sin against your own fandom. You just stole candy from the world's most important baby. You ripped off your own fans. You are scum. Even if you hadn't meant to, there is no way that you can prove that you didn't nick off somebody else's ideas.
所以我认为主要原因是你会担心，如果你读了同人小说，然后你写了任何模仿别人关于你的财产所写的东西，你就犯下了针对你自己粉丝群体的一个巨大罪孽。你刚从世界上最重要的宝宝那里偷了糖果。你剽窃了你自己的粉丝。你是渣滓。即使你并非有意，你也没有办法证明你不是偷了别人的想法。
Tamsyn says that writers in general are told pretty firmly to not read fanfic about their work. There needs to be no question of where their ideas come from. Earlier this year, a fanfic writer sued the Tolkien Estate and Amazon Studios for $250 million, alleging they'd ripped off his storyline for The Lord of the Rings prequel. The Tolkien Trust countersued for copyright infringement.
Tamsyn说作家通常被强烈建议不要读关于他们作品的同人。必须对想法的来源没有疑问。今年早些时候，一名同人小说作家起诉托尔金基金会和亚马逊工作室，索赔2.5亿美元，称他们剽窃了他的《指环王》前传情节。托尔金基金会反诉版权侵权。
If you look up Tamsyn's work on the big fic sites today, there are thousands of entries, people writing, interacting, playing around in the world of The Locked Tomb. Tamsyn can't participate in any of it. And it kills her because, again, these are her people. And now that it's about her own books even more so her people.
如果你今天在大型同人网站上查找Tamsyn的作品，有成千上万的条目，人们在写作、互动、在《锁墓》的世界里玩耍。Tamsyn不能参与其中任何一个。这让她很难受，因为，再次强调，这些是她的人。既然是关于她自己的书，就更是她的人了。
Not only do they like the same books, but they are devoted to her characters, her humor, the entire fantastical sci-fi universe that lives in her head. So the people who loved it were like a custom-made group of people who could not possibly have interests more tailored to Tamsyn's own brain, all milling around in one spot.
他们不仅喜欢同样的书，而且他们致力于她的角色、她的幽默，整个活在她脑海里的幻想科幻宇宙。所以那些爱它的人就像一个量身定做的群体，不可能有比这更符合Tamsyn大脑兴趣的人了，全部聚集在一个点上。
Do you have questions about what's going on in--
你对那里发生的事情有疑问吗——
Oh, so many. I want to know everything. Because fandom is so deeply about shipping, whose faces do you want to make mush together? I'm just sitting here, eating popcorn, being like, who do you want to make mush? Come on. Who are you making kiss? I want to figure it out.
噢，太多了。我想知道一切。因为粉丝圈深深关于配对，你想把谁的脸揉在一起？我就坐在这，吃着爆米花，想着，你想让谁揉在一起？来吧。你在让谁接吻？我想弄明白。
And then, when I realized that I wasn't going to be able to do that, I'm the kind of person who doesn't do anything by halves. I'm all in or I'm all out. And I realized then that just being a writer, I kind of didn't want to interact with anyone at all. I was all about that hermit lifestyle.
然后，当我意识到我无法做到这一点时，我属于那种凡事不做半途的人。我要么全心投入，要么完全退出。我那时意识到作为作家，我其实并不想和任何人互动。我全心全意投入了那种隐士生活。
Oh, yeah. I mean, it seems like it must be hard to avoid. You're just a couple keystrokes away just to quickly peek. Is it ever hard?
噢，是的。我的意思是，这看起来一定很难避免。你只需要几下键盘就能快速偷看。这真的很难吗？
It's impossible. That's why most of the internet is banned. I have a beautiful program called Freedom, and I have banned myself from looking pretty much anywhere, because I know I would go look, I would go look at everything. So I had to be sensible, and I've banned myself from fandom.
这是不可能的。这就是为什么互联网大部分被禁了。我有一个名为“Freedom”的漂亮程序，我禁止自己去看任何地方，因为我知道我会去看，我会去看一切。所以我必须明智，我禁止了自己进入粉丝圈。
You had to exile yourself.
你不得不流放自己。
I have exiled myself. I have left. I have gone into the West.
我已经流放了自己。我离开了。我已经前往西方。
That seems like it would have its own kind of melancholy.
那似乎会有它自己那种忧郁。
Yeah. Yeah, it's lonely. You know how I said I wanted no loneliness? I got loneliness.
是的。是的，很孤独。你知道我说过我不想要孤独吗？我得到了孤独。
Wow.
哇。
Yeah. It's a particular kind of melancholy that I didn't think I would ever experience.
是的。那是一种我从没想过我会经历的特定忧郁。
Talking to her, somehow I couldn't help but tell her what it was like being in that world among her fans. I told her about that summer vacation I spent listening to her book together with friends, how we bought a little boat and named it Ianthe. It was one of the characters in the books, a villain. People online call her a Draco in leather pants.
与她交谈，不知怎的，我不禁告诉她置身于她粉丝的世界中是什么感觉。我告诉她那个我与朋友们一起听她书的暑假，我们买了一艘小船，命名为Ianthe。它是书中的角色之一，一个反派。网民称她为“皮裤里的Draco”。
That boat's going to sink. Why would you name your boat Ianthe? Your boat's cursed.
那船会沉的。为什么要把你的船命名为Ianthe？你的船被诅咒了。
We would jump off of it into the lake and yell "Ianthe" as we were jumping into the lake.
我们会从船上跳进湖里，在我们跳进湖里时大喊“Ianthe”。
Sorry. I don't mean to roast you about the boat. It's just, that's the greatest thing I've ever heard.
抱歉。我不是故意要嘲笑你的船。只是，那是我听过的最棒的事情。
Fandom around her books, speaking from experience, it's really fun. This is what she's missing.
她书周围的粉丝圈，以我的经验来说，真的很有趣。这就是她错过的。
It's like you created this whole world that would be perfect for you and perfect for your 17-year-old self.
就像你创造了这个整个世界，对你来说是完美的，对你17岁的自己也是完美的。
It's your own world, and you can't even post there. You've created the perfect thing for you, and you're on the outside of it. You've been monkey's pawed. You've created the perfect fandom, and you can never walk inside it.
那是你自己的世界，而你甚至不能在那里发帖。你创造了对自己完美的东西，却站在它的外面。你被“猴爪”了。你创造了完美的粉丝圈，却永远不能走进它。
Yeah, yeah.
是的，是的。
You know how Frodo says that he saved the Shire, but not for himself? It's like that, except Frodo wasn't blocking his own name on Twitter.
你知道Frodo说他拯救了夏尔，但不是为了他自己？就是那样，除了Frodo没有在Twitter上屏蔽他自己的名字。
She's also come to accept, this is their party. If she arrives, it's like the teacher showing up and trying to hang with the students. Her very presence means that no one can act normal. And she understands that, but it's OK, she says. She gets to spend plenty of time in the universe of The Locked Tomb. She's still at work writing the end of the series for the rest of us to enjoy without her.
她也接受了，这是他们的派对。如果她出现，就像老师出现试图和学生打成一片。她的存在意味着没人能表现正常。她理解这一点，但这没关系，她说。她有足够的时间在《锁墓》的宇宙里消磨。她仍然在写这个系列的结尾，让我们这些人在没有她的情况下享受。
Lilly Sullivan is a producer on our show. The third book in Tamsyn Muir's Locked Tomb series, Nona the Ninth, just came out in paperback.
Lilly Sullivan是我们节目的制作人。Tamsyn Muir的《锁墓》系列第三本书《九号Nona》刚刚出了平装本。
Today's program was produced by Diane Wu and edited by our senior editor David Kestenbaum. The people who put together our show today include Jane Ackermann, James Bennett II, Phia Bennin, Zoe Chace, Sean Cole, Michael Comite, Aviva DeKornfeld, Cassie Howley, Valerie Kipnis, Seth Lind, Tobin Low, Stowe Nelson, Katherine Rae Mondo, Nadia Reiman, Ryan Rumery, Alyssa Shipp, Alix Spiegel, Christopher Swetala, and Matt Tierney.
今天的节目由Diane Wu制作，资深编辑David Kestenbaum编辑。今天整理我们节目的人员包括Jane Ackermann、James Bennett II、Phia Bennin、Zoe Chace、Sean Cole、Michael Comite、Aviva DeKornfeld、Cassie Howley、Valerie Kipnis、Seth Lind、Tobin Low、Stowe Nelson、Katherine Rae Mondo、Nadia Reiman、Ryan Rumery、Alyssa Shipp、Alix Spiegel、Christopher Swetala和Matt Tierney。
Our managing editor is Sarah Abdurrahman. Our executive editor is Emanuele Berry. Special thanks today to Noriko Meek, Caro Perny, Taylor Britton, and Mikafui Dzotsi.
我们的管理编辑是Sarah Abdurrahman。我们的执行编辑是Emanuele Berry。今天特别感谢Noriko Meek、Caro Perny、Taylor Britton和Mikafui Dzotsi。
Interpretation for act one by Siyi Chen and Yukiko Hata, with research help from Zeyi Yang, Hisae Kawamori, Kiku Matsuo, Karin Jeffery, and Japanese voice over by Toshiji Takeshima.
第一幕的翻译由Siyi Chen和Yukiko Hata完成，研究协助来自Zeyi Yang、Hisae Kawamori、Kiku Matsuo、Karin Jeffery，日语配音由Toshiji Takeshima完成。
Our website, thisamericanlife.org, where you can stream our archive of over 800 episodes for absolutely free. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange.
我们的网站thisamericanlife.org，在那里你可以免费流媒体播放我们超过800集的档案。《美国生活》由公共广播交换平台PRX分发到公共广播电台。
Thanks, as always, to my boss Ira Glass. He's recently started coaching a team of amateur bobsledders. The vibe is supposed to be super relaxed. No one's keeping score. But he's also really competitive, wants his team members to get the fastest times. You can hear how conflicted he is each time he shoves them down the track.
感谢一如既往的老板Ira Glass。他最近开始指导一支业余雪橇队。氛围本应该是超级放松的。没人记分。但他真的很有竞争力，希望他的队员拿到最快成绩。每次他把他们推下赛道时，你都能听到他有多纠结。
Hurry. Have fun. Ahh!
快点。玩得开心。啊！
I'm Bim Adewunmi, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是Bim Adewunmi，下周带回更多《美国生活》的故事。